teddy knows that a figure has a surface
area of 40 square centimeters the net
below has five centimeter and two
centimeter edges could the net below
represent the figure so let's just make
sure we understand what this here
represents
so it tells us that it has five
centimeter edges so this is one of the
five centimeter edges right over here
and we know that has several other five
centimeter edges because any edge that
has this double hash mark right over
here is also going to be five
centimeters so this edge is also five
centimeters this is also five
centimeters
this is also five centimeters
and then these two over here are also
five centimeters so that's five
centimeters and that's five centimeters
and then we have several two centimeter
edges so this one is two centimeters and
any other edge that has the same number
of hash marks in this case one is also
going to be two centimeters so all of
these other edges
pretty much all the rest of the edges
are going to be two centimeters now they
don't ask us to do this in the problem
but it's always fun to start with a net
like this and try to visualize the
polyhedron that it actually represents
it looks pretty clear this is going to
be a rectangular prism but let's
actually draw it so if we were to we're
going to fold this in we're going to
fold this
that way this will be you could view
this as our base right over here we're
going to fold this in we're going to
fold that up and then this is going to
be our top this is the top right over
here this polyhedron is going to look
something like this so you're going to
have your base
you're going to have your base
that has
a length of 5 centimeters so this is our
base let me do that in a new color
so this is our base
right over here i'll do it in the same
color
so that's our base
this dimension right over here i can put
the double hash marks if i want five
centimeters and that's of course the
same as that dimension up there
now when we fold up
when we fold up this side this is an
orange actually when we fold up that
side that could be this side right over
here
this side right over here along this two
centimeter edge so that's that side
right over here when you fold this side
in
right over here that could be that
that's that side right over
there and then when of course we fold
this side in that's the same color let
me do a different color when we fold
this side in
that's the side that's kind of facing us
a little bit so that's that right over
there
that's that right over there
color that in a little bit better and
then we can fold
this side in
and that would be that side
and then of course we have the top
that's connected right over here so the
top would go
this would be the
top and then the top would of course go
on top of our rectangular prism so
that's the figure that we're talking
about it's five centimeters in this
dimension it is two centimeters
two centimeters tall
and it is two centimeters two
centimeters wide but let's go back to
the original question
is this thing's surface area 40 square
centimeters
well the good thing about this net here
is it's laid out all of the surfaces for
us and we just have to figure out the
surface area of each of these sections
and then add them together the surface
area of each of these surfaces
so what is the surface area of this one
here well it's going to be 5 centimeters
times 2 centimeters so it's going to be
10 square centimeters same thing for
this one it's going to be five by two
five by two this one is five by two so
these are each ten square centimeters
and so is this one this is five long
five centimeters long two centimeters
wide so once again that's 10 square
centimeters now these two sections right
over here they're two centimeters by two
centimeters so they're each going to be
four square centimeters so what's the
total surface area well 10 plus 10 plus
10 plus 10 is 40 plus 4 plus 4 gets us
to 48
square centimeters or centimeters
squared so could the net represent could
the net below represent the figure that
has a surface area of 40 square
centimeters no
this represents a figure that has a
surface area of 48 square centimeters